on a tellement bousillée par la
pollution visuelle quand on est
important que je crois que les gens ne
regardent plus je suis il faut que je
trouve quelque chose de nouveau qui ré
interpelle les gens et du coup il y
avait les l'avènement des drones qui ne
devait ni une nouvelle vision sur le
monde qui disait de la littérature
bouddhistes et puis des revues
scientifiques sur l'écologie j'ai mixé
mon passé de graffeurs est ce que je
lisais plus l'avènement des drones et je
me suis mis à peindre
[Musique]
c'est vraiment de la cuisine ça c'est
bling c'est un pigment naturel ça donne
une couleur un peu bleuté en gros c'est
du charbon ces sandales noires et puis
après de la craie pour faire du blanc et
après je mixe les deux ça me fait
minérale
mais
[Musique]
on a une banque de données maintenant on
a pris des gens connus les footballeurs
des politiciens avec des gens pas connu
du tout des gens qui ont des migrants
des réfugiés une même mois en fait à un
moment donné on sait plus d'où viennent
les photos c'est la logique du pôle est
[Musique]
solution opex en tout cas ya une chose
qu'on sait c'est qu'elle ne peut pas
être ça ne peut pas être de les laisser
prix on va atteindre bientôt depuis le
début de la crise migratoire peut être
environ et c'est sûrement sous-estimé 60
nord près de nos côtes
vingt mille dans les dernières années ça
peut évidemment le pape
ça ne peut pas être ça
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]